Speaker 1: Let's go next
to Alex from Orange County.
Speaker 4: They do it, can you hear
me? Yes, I can. So have you covered
what's going on in Texas and Texas Democrats,
Speaker 1: we covered it on the Wednesday bonus
show. Yeah, it's crazy. Basically, I'll explain
to people who don't know just real quick before
you get to your question. Texas Republicans
want to pass restrictive voting rights.
Texas Democrats don't have a majority.
And so their idea was prevent a quorum.
Texas Republicans said we're going to have state
troopers drag you in. So Texas Democrats left the
state and Texas Republicans want state troopers
to leave Texas and to drag Democrats back.
Speaker 4: So my question is, do you feel
like the Democrats efforts are futile? Do
you feel like. Yes, just.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen,
you don't have the majority eventually. They're
almost certainly going to get a vote on this.
But I do think that given this and given the toxic
and corrosive and disenfranchizing nature of the
voting restrictions that I like, Democrats
are doing what they can to delay it
and showing the crazy lengths to which Republicans
are willing to go to drag them back. But I
do think ultimately they're going to get a vote.
Speaker 4: So what needs to be changed? You need a
Democratic.
Speaker 1:
I'm sorry, did you say a
Democratic majority you cut out?
Speaker 4: Democratic governor like
some like Democratic leadership,
Speaker 1: like, I guess I mean, so listen,
the first thing would be for Texas to be run
by a governor and state legislature
leaders that don't want to do this crazy
stuff. That would be step one. The other
idea would be to really have super strong
federal limitations on what states are allowed to
do in terms of voting rights. That would be the
other way to prevent this from being an issue.
Speaker 4: All right. Interesting that you
say it and thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thank you for calling
in. Very, very important question and one that is
very, very relevant right now. Why don't we speak
next? Wow, the phone lines are just packed,
we might need to widen the discord tubes in
order to allow more people in. Why don't we
go next to Michael from is it Baco or Bako?
Speaker 4: Hi, yes, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Yeah, it's Bakersfield's
is short for Bakersville. Oh, I
Speaker 1: didn't know that was
a nickname for Bakersfield's
Speaker 4: like it's like a nickname. Yeah.
So my name is Michael. Yes. So my question
is, have you ever considered for
future like have you considered
running for president like twenty, twenty four.
Speaker 1: I am not eligible to be president due
to not being born in the United States.
Speaker 4: OK, understood. Yeah. OK,
well that was my question. Thank you. Have a great
Speaker 1: day. I mean I'm still considering
it. I just legally can't be
president so I don't know what,
Speaker 4: what, what if, what if they ever
change it then I will absolutely be there.
Perfect. Thank you. Have a great day.
Speaker 1: Now, that's a perfect
phone call if I've ever heard one